[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire de ce 18 mars la solidarité
qui continuent de s'organiser face aux
conflits en ukraine parmi les
initiatives celle des pizzaïolos de
france qui ont lancé un appel national
pour soutenir les ukrainiens aux chaînés
rocancourt huit commerces ont répondu
présent ils proposeront des repas à
petit prix l'intégralité des recettes
servira à acheter des denrées
alimentaires la solidarité pour
l'ukraine justement mais aussi la
suspension du pass vaccinale ou encore
un nouveau pôle culturel qui se profile
à montigny le bretonneux l'actualité de
la semaine à une nouvelle fois été riche
dans les yvelines on vous résume le tout
en 78 secondes enfin comme chaque
vendredi notre sélection des idées de
sorties pour le week-end et pour les
jours à venir dans le département
[Musique]
tout est parti de laurent raimondo qui
est le président de l'association des
pizzaïolos qui a proposé il nous envoie
un message groupe et nous dit on pourra
peut-être faire quelque chose pour les
ukrainiens c'est parti de là et puis
proposé dix mois menton sur la place de
menton bah voilà
je vais faire venir des fours et puis
enfin des maria rita temps à vendre
toutes ses journées comme ça voire deux
joueurs des pizzas
[Musique]
moins fertiles marie à l'étagé part que
les clients viennent pas juste pour une
sorte de pizza pour ma part que ce sera
une formule à 10 euros déjà port du
bonnet c'est plus facile et où il y aura
une margarita une chèvre ou une
sicilienne avec la boisson pour 10 euros
il y aura des associations qui ont
offert des desserts vente de boissons
tout ça des cuisiniers qui vont vendre
des plats cuisinés pareil des desserts
des boissons et à la fin de la journée
voilà on fait les comptes y attend
tentant chacun fera un chèque
directement à l'association des
pizzaïolos et forcément avec un reçu de
simples euros pour avoir une traçabilité
le but voilà c'est d'acheter un maximum
pour pour les aider
ça va se trouver sur l'avenue du tard
donc la vie on fait tous les événements
du chesnay à savoir les chaînes vers la
brocante par tous les évènements se
passent ici pour des raisons logistiques
plus d'habitude depuis des années des
années et ça va se passer le dimanche
qui arrivera le 20 mars de 11h à 19h
[Musique]
nouvelle étape dans l'allègement du
protocole sanitaire lundi signé la fin
du pass vaccinale et du port du masque
pour les entreprises les commerces et
les écoles seule exception les
transports et les établissements de
santé le pôle culturel de montigny le
bretonneux a pris place au centre
aznavour depuis lundi il comprendra
notamment un auditorium de 150 places et
un studio d'enregistrement
inauguration prévue les 26 et 27 mars
prochains il vient en partenariat avec
renault et plug power a inauguré sa
première chaîne d'assemblage de
batteries à hydrogène à flins ces
batteries alimenteront les futurs
véhicules renault elles permettront en
véhicules électriques d'avoir plus
d'autonomie le club de nationale 2 de
l'aef football poissy a accueilli cinq
joueurs ukrainiens professionnelle et
leur entraîneur sur leur pelouse une
initiative du président du club lui-même
d'origine ukrainienne et la générosité
continue l'équivalent de 40 pau-lourdes
dons ont été collectés par les commune
yvelinoise ils ont été rassemblées par
le département et partiront pour
l'ukraine
enfin la sixième édition de la job
academy a débuté au château de
versailles demandeurs d'emploi et
professionnels de l'établissement se
sont rencontrés ils ont travaillé en
binôme pendant trois mois la mission des
parrains accompagner leurs filleuls vers
un emploi pérenne
[Musique]
au fond
dans son projet électoral valérie
pécresse souhaite abaisser la majorité
pénale des mineurs à 16 ans pour tenir
compte de l'évolution de la criminalité
ce qui aurait pour conséquence la
comparution du délinquant devant une
juridiction pénale de droit commun la
suppression de l'excusé de minorité et
l'atténuation de sa responsabilité
toutefois en droit cette proposition
serait compliquée à mettre en oeuvre
premier obstacle le droit international
en effet la france a ratifié la
convention internationale de 1989 sur
les droits de l'enfant qui précise qu'un
enfant et tout être humain de moins de
18 ans et qui par conséquent ne peut pas
être traitée pénalement comme un adulte
elle a également ratifié en 2007 la
convention européenne sur l'exercice des
droits des enfants qui s'applique aux
moins de 18 ans
donc pour s'extraire de l'application de
ces conventions la france devrait
adopter une loi abaissant l'âge de la
majorité civile en france toutefois il
n'est pas certain que la législation
française soit conforme aux obligations
internationales
second obstacle la reconnaissance en
2002 par le conseil constitutionnel du
principe de valeur constitutionnelle
d'atténuation de la responsabilité des
mineurs en fonction de leur âge une
façon en réalité très explicite de dire
qu'un mineur ne peut pas être jugés
pénalement comme un majeur en outre le
conseil impose également la
spécialisation des juridictions pour les
mineurs alors on le constate une telle
réforme de la législation pénale
française serait potentiellement
contraire non seulement au bloc de
constitutionnalité mais aussi serait
probablement non conforme aux
conventions internationales
par ailleurs l'application de cette
proposition serait délicate et poserait
d'autres questions supplémentaires comme
le droit de vote le mariage où les
capacités financières
et puis surtout le code de la justice
pénale des mineurs prévoit déjà la
possibilité de lever l'excusé de
minorité et la comparution devant une
juridiction spécialisée pour les mineurs
pour les mineurs de 16 ans selon la
gravité du délit ou du crime donc le
juge peut déjà appliqué les sanctions
pénales prévues par les majeures ou
mineures de 16 et 18 ans au final une
proposition peu innovante est source de
complexité
l'invité de ce cette fuite week end
weber bonjour sept conseillers pour les
entreprises avec une société qui
s'appelle in men où ils trustent qui est
à paris et versailles notamment vous
avez dirigé la culture pour dans l'auto
au débat au département des yvelines et
on va parler avec vous de
procrastination
consacré hier un livre à la
procrastination qui s'appelle powerful
procrastination et va y avoir la journée
internationale de la procrastination
c'est le 25 mars
pourquoi d'abord yen cette journée
internationale c'est quoi la journée
internationale des feignants
justement est justement trop souvent en
fait on considère que la procrastination
est un vilain défaut qu'il faut
combattre et la journée mondiale a été
créé il ya une dizaine d'années par des
15 villes qui comme moi est persuadé que
c'est quelque chose de joyeux et
d'intéressant et d'agréable d'où ce
premier petit guide parce que quand
alors faut dire ce que c'est la
procrastination c'est le fait de
remettre au lendemain ce qu'on pourrait
faire le jour ma main on a repris dans
le livre la définition du larousse qui
dit tendance pathologique a différé
parce que nausicaa théologie pathologie
guéant ni quand encontre recherche
procrastination lee l'indécision lille
atermoiements le la paresse un ccd bout
qui reviennent à chaque fois qu'on parle
de ça et vous vous dites pas du tout
l'idée maîtresse en fête du livre qui
est basée sur 20 ans d'expérience
d'études des talents naturels humains
c'est que ce talent qui est un talent
parmi beaucoup d'autres en fait certains
de vos auditeurs ne posséderont
peut-être pas eh bien c'est la capacité
à comprendre la complexité et à calculer
les meilleurs scénarios possibles
comment puis-je faire pour ela comment
dire il ya mille choses derrière et se
calcule en fait ce super calculateur ne
se lance que quand on est sûr d'avoir
tous les éléments hors temps qui a pas
de délai de deadline ou de rendu et bien
demain n'aura peut-être encore d'autres
éléments puis encore d'autres
informations
donc finalement ce supercalculateur ne
se lance pas
séparation kitty et is it c'est
quelqu'un qui réfléchit au fond tout en
plus tôt fait et qui va donner le
meilleur scénario possible c'est
intéressant par exemple de noter que
parmi nos clients on va retrouver des
gens qui font merveille dans des pc de
crise parce que il y a des deadlines ce
site web de l'entreprise où ils ont fait
le grand écart notre premier client il
ya sept ans maintenant c'est dassault
systèmes on travaille pour airbus pour
des start up de façon large et est tout
à fait il ya plein de procrastinateurs
très puissant dans toutes ses
entreprises si on revient à l'histoire
et yann alors il ya des grands artistes
qui sauvait progresse-t-il auteuil yakhi
léonard de vinci à mozaria victor hugo
coucou cédé hier qu'ils étaient
procrastinateurs haut parce que comme on
dire on a toute une série d'anecdotes
certains par exemple confié leurs habits
à leurs domestiques pour ne plus pouvoir
sortir et être obligé de finir il ya une
célèbre histoire de pêche au piège pour
tous les gens curieux il ya un petit
documentaire du mini série d'arte et qui
s'appelle excursions procrastination qui
reprend toutes ces anecdotes historiques
en une dizaine de minutes c'est quoi la
pêche au petit côté nous quand même
aubin je vous laisse comment tu peux
garder un sentiment c'est vraiment bien
fait c'est une
très très belle c'est donc voilà on peut
être un peu entre un grand artiste est
au progrès stinger on peut être
important dans une entreprise est
procrastinateurs est ce que quand même
il n'y a pas une pression sociale qui
fait que l'on dit c'est pas bien quoi
tout à fait lorsqu'ils doivent être au
lendemain de remettre au lendemain ce qu
il ya même de ce proverbe ne remet pas
au lendemain ce que tu pourrais faire le
jour même c'est une maxime quoi fait il
ya deux éléments un il ya quelques
autres notions qu'on peut confondre et
la procrastination l'addiction aux
écrans la difficulté à se concentrer ou
alors un épisode traumatique très
important dans la vie peuvent impacter
le passage à l'acte ça c'est clair on
leur donne des clés dans le livre que
les gens puissent aller chercher les
bonnes ressources mais ce qui est
important c'est que on est dans une
société qui va systématiquement regarder
l'individu par rapport à une norme et
donc du coup on est plutôt mis dans des
cases ce qui est réjouissant c'est qu'on
est tous absolument unique et que quand
on s'intéresse aux à l'unicité de chaque
individu tout à l'heure vous at il
intéressé quand on a préparé l'émission
on a une chance sur 470 mille milliards
de rencontrer quelqu'un qui a le même
set nos talents utiles au quotidien
d'être unique complètement il n'y a pas
deux patrick carmouze à l'échelle de la
planète alors si vous êtes
procrastinateurs et ben voilà
précipitez-vous sur ce livre power foule
procrastination la journée
internationale c'est le 25 mars je ne
sais pas pourquoi ne pas reporter au 26
mai enfin
il pourrait quand même un point ce
serait la moindre des choses merci
beaucoup à tous est belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vendredi soir nous allons recevoir
plusieurs groupes sur la place philippe
prévôt ainsi qu'un ensemble de brasseurs
donc c'est des brasseries locales qui
faisait place et je tiens à les
remercier ses artisans vous permettent
vont offrir un ensemble de deux saveurs
des dégustations pour nos papilles il a
fait de masse et la saint-patrick le
vendredi soir et au vu des différents
événements qui ont eu lieu on a décidé
d'orienter cette fête de manière
solidaire et 2 et ainsi permet de
récolter des dons collectés des affaires
des objets du matériel médical à
destination de l'ukraine
[Musique]
on a aussi le week-end le samedi
dimanche le salon du vin et de la
gourmandise donc là vous pourrez trouver
un ensemble de stands pour justement
apprécié beaucoup de choses et de salon
il y aura bien entendu une urne toujours
à destination de l'ukraine
[Musique]
c'est une place qui permet de fédérer un
ensemble de personnes d'activités aussi
et surtout
philippe prévôt c'était le président des
comédiens de la tour c'est une
association qui aide depuis des dizaines
d'années sur triel et y organise des
spectacles de théâtre de manière
régulière donc c'était parfaitement
adaptés finalement d'avoir un espace une
place au centre culturel avec une
personne qui a dédié toute sa vie à la
culture
[Musique]
le manège royal de saint germain en laye
habité d'un esprit familial d'un père et
son fils stéphane bosco a tenu à
investir la galerie d'art pour rendre
hommage à son aïeul c'est l'exposition
de l'oeuvre une exposition et strauss
pectives de l'oeuvre de mon père pia
bosco qui était peintre à saint germain
en laye qui a vécu toute sa vie à saint
germain en laye qui est arrivé ici en
1931 en tout environ 250 oeuvres sont
exposées de la peinture au couteau dont
la série la plus reconnue de l'artiste
voilà d une peinture caractéristiques de
mon de mon père sur les courses de
chevaux qui sont justement cette matière
mise en mouvement on voit bien le
mouvement le mouvement des shows durant
leurs courses c'est pas le sujet qui
était le plus important dans son dans
son travail mais c'est bien la manière
dont il le traitait donc il a fait des
séries proviseur du lycée jean moulin au
chesnay stéphane bosco à monter
l'exposition en partenariat avec
plusieurs lycées professionnels toutes
ces parois que vous voyez la façon dont
ça a été pensé tout le cheminement de
l'exposition a été pensé par les élèves
et leurs professeurs on affine maquettes
dans les assemblées comme on l'a fait au
début de
du montage des meubles et après
on a commencé il ya deux jours à monter
les meubles ici c'est plutôt cool parce
qu'on voit les ce qu'on a créé pendant
plusieurs années enfin créer enfin
naître et coup c'est plutôt cool
satisfaisant la fiche a été pensé par
des élèves du lycée caraman à colombes
et les visuels par le lycée jean perrin
à saint-cyr-l'ecole déjà jeu là c'est
très beau alors finalisé parce que ça va
être vraiment pas mal trop ça va être
bien en fait de voir le résultat qu'est
ce que ça va donner en voyant du coup
comment on a installé les choses de
venir voir l'exposition quand elle sera
quand elle sera faite et du coup là
normalement on aura tous posé
[Musique]
la rétrospective d'une vie consacrée au
travail de mise en mouvement de la
matière à visiter dès ce vendredi 18
mars il faut redécouvrir cette cette
oeuvre qui est une oeuvre très original
qui a une très grande force ia j'avais
deux artistes avec moi qu'ils
connaissaient pas le travail de mon père
qui sont deux jeunes artistes assez
connu dans le milieu parisien et quand
ils ont découvert cette oeuvre ils ont
été enthousiastes l'exposition est en
accès libre jusqu'au 27 mars tous les
jours de 13h à 19h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]